one word to describe your finale
emotional for a lot of reasons the
Bachelorette airs its finale Monday
nights with Rachel Lindsay choosing
between Peter Eric and Brian we spoke to
some of her former guys at the men tell
all special taping to find out how they
thought things would end who do you
think Rachel should pick and who do you
think she will pick Rachel should have
picked Kenny outside of that I'm really
impressed with Eric and Eric's the guy
who really kind of like took those fears
head-on and he mastered them any
conquered him so I'm team Eric go away
probably Brian neither now that I'm team
Eric I I'm also seeing Brian and I just
feel like Brian Brian's 37 he's that
Brian has no qualms about who he is or
what he wants and I believe that's what
Rachel likes you say all the right I
think she should pick Eric Eric I got
very close with in the house he's one of
the most genuine light hearted guys that
I've ever met my whole life and I think
that he possesses a lot of things that
she would want in a man and for that I
think he should get it
I actually roomed with Brian on two
different hotels when we were traveling
just to get to know him better and I'd
like Brian a lot I think his intentions
are very good it's interesting seeing
how things are being played back and I'm
like interesting Brian but I think the
one thing I really do like about Brian
is he's all-in and I think that's a
trait that has kept him there as long as
it has and hopefully you know Rachel she
can she knows that I think she should
and I hope she picks Eric Eric's at the
point where he does a good job of
keeping her light-hearted he has flying
and he's done a good job authentically
being here for Rachel I care about your
well-being I care about what she doing
laughing about
you are with Peter and Brian and Eric I
felt like she couldn't go wrong who fits
best and who's sincere and who's really
ready for to take that step because she
said I don't want to leave here with a
boyfriend I want to leave here engaged
so who's ready to step up and actually
do that I should be able to get down on
one knee and propose to her and